Hi, I'm Andrey and I'm an
engineer on Google News team.
I'm here to talk
about some things
we learned about building
performant web UI
while building the
Google News phone
and tablet mobile web apps.
I'll describe how
we worked around
the shortcomings
of mobile devices
and took advantage of
modern browser features
and ultimately delivered
engaging and fast news
experiences.
Mobile devices are rapidly
becoming the dominant platform
to access online
content and services.
Rapid growth of mobile devices
present a great opportunity,
but also come with their own
set of technical and product
challenges.
Technically, mobile
devices generally
suffer from slow and unreliable
networks, limited memory,
relatively weak CPU and GPU,
and, of course, limited screen
size.
At the same time, most mobile
devices have modern OSs
and have browsers which are
HTML5 compliant with features
like local storage
and touch events.
This opens new ways to
create engaging web apps.
One of the most prominent
challenges of phones
is slow network connections.
This means that phone apps
should limit data consumption
to as little as possible
on the connection.
Now, this may prompt
developers to retrieve
as little data as possible
in one data connection
and make frequent data calls.
This approach could
backfire, as opening
a connection is quite
expensive and time-consuming.
So a balance needs
to be maintained
between data transfer on one
connection and opening multiple
connections.
On Google News, we balance this
by getting all the textual data
of the phone web app in
one call to the server.
Images are fetched later
on-- as they are not
critical to the news
reading experience--
as are various scripts
and resources which
are not immediately needed.
Another workaround
to slow connections
is to optimize data access
around product usage patterns.
In Google News,
we try to predict
what the user would do next
and prefetch that data.
This means we can
show content to users
as quickly as possible.
For example, when a user
swipes to a section,
it's a good indication
that user could
swipe to the next section
of our app as well.
In that case, we prefetch
the next few sections
while the user is active
on the current section.
Another technique that
we use is to fetch
partial concept of
a page beforehand.
For example, we retrieve
the first article
of all news stories while
fetching a section page data.
When the user navigates
to a story page,
we display the first
article immediately
while fetching other
articles on the news story.
We'll also show a silhouette
instead of an empty white space
while fetching the
rest of the story page.
This gives users some content
to interact with immediately
and indicates to the
user that more content
is being retrieved.
Static resources such as
JavaScript, CSS, and sprites
can be stored in local storage.
Thus, the application
will avoid making
HTTP HEAD calls to verify
that the cached browser
version of the file
is good to use.
This saves a few round
trips to the server.
So these are some of the
transport layer considerations,
but what about mobile
browser level optimizations?
Well, the [INAUDIBLE]
rendering of that
by browser internals
in the CPU and GPU
have many more
deficiencies compared
to typical desktop or
laptop machines today.
You must be careful when
manipulating and accessing
properties of DOM
elements, as it
may result in full
or partial screen
delay in the [INAUDIBLE].
Use Chrome Dev
Tool's timeline view
to see what the browser spends
time doing frame by frame.
And you can turn on various
experimental settings that
show internal drawing and
[INAUDIBLE] of the browser.
When moving HTML5
elements on the screen--
especially in the response to
user gestures-- use HTML5 3D
transforms.
This will offload [INAUDIBLE]
processing to the GPU,
resulting in a much
smoother experience.
GPU memory is quite
limited, so try
to move only the elements
which are visible
and hide the invisible
sides of elements.
For elements that
are about to appear
on the screen-- like when a
pane is about to be swiped
onto a screen--
it's very helpful
to bring them into the DOM
structure well ahead of time.
And make them
renderable, meaning, you
need to set CSS display property
to something other than none.
Browsers are typically capable
of performing layout and pane
of several screen elements
on a separate thread,
often prioritizing among
different elements based
on distance to visible viewport.
If you absolutely need
to animate something
with JavaScript, use the
RequestAnimationFrame API
callbacks to synchronize
DOM changes with the vsync.
Everything we've
talked about so far
is also good practice when
developing other non-mobile web
applications.
But one key feature that
singles out mobile applications
is that they are controlled
through gestures.
Natively, browsers
support vertical swipes
through the vertical scroll
of the main body element.
But if you want your
application to respond
to horizontal swipe or
other gestures like pinch,
you'll need to process raw
touch events in JavaScript
and animate appropriate
parts of the UI.
To do so, the
touchstart event should
be processed in the
consecutive touchmove.
And ultimate touchend
events should also
be processed in this JavaScript.
And this is where
it gets tricky.
For UI to appear
smooth, all transitions
should run at about
60 frames per second
which leaves about 60
milliseconds per frame.
The main thread that's
responsible for reporting
and executing application
specific touchevent handlers
must complete script
execution and browser
paning within those
60 milliseconds.
What this means is that code
in touchstart-- and especially
touchmove handlers--
should complete
in no more than a
few milliseconds.
For comparison,
full-screen layout in pane
might take 20 to 30
milliseconds resulting
in several skipped frames.
The thing that allows 40
panes to be quick is CSS 3D
transforms, which move elements
on screen as raster images
rather than trying to
repane DOM structure.
Once you've optimized
touchevent handlers,
you can do browser
level optimizations
to streamline browser
event processing
and reduce overhead associated
with event DOM propagation.
One way to achieve this is
to listen to all touch events
on a single top-level DOM
element in capture mode.
This will result in no DOM
event propagation chipping
valuable milliseconds
from touch event
processing on the main thread.
In our phone web app we
wrote a small framework
that did just that.
It processed raw touch events
at the top-level element,
converted these touch events to
gestures-- such as drag-left,
drag-right, up and down--
and routed these gestures
to the appropriate subcomponent
of the application based
on subcomponent
reported [INAUDIBLE],
for which it should be
notified of gestures.
The last topic of this talk
is phone versus tablet UI.
A common debate is how different
phone and tablet UIs should be.
One school of thought is
to have responsive websites
where a site is
automatically adjusted
to the available screen
size and capabilities.
In our experience, this
approach doesn't work very well.
First, a UI that adjusts
dynamically results
in complicated code and
limits optimization choices.
But more importantly,
what we have found
is that phone and
tablet consumption
models are very different.
Phone consumption happens
more frequently in a day,
but a session lasts
only a few minutes.
This is what we call
the "snacking" mode
of news consumption.
This means it is much better
to have an information-dense
and more summarized
view of news.
Whereas tablet
usage is very much
limited to morning
and evening hours
with the user interacting for
an extended period of time.
So it made much more sense
to provide in-depth reading
choices on tablets.
We hope this talk will help
you avoid some common pitfalls
of web development
on mobile platforms
and will inspire you to
code slick and fun web
applications for
many users to enjoy.
Thank you and see you
at news.google.com.